[Music]
we have to be stewards of our
environment we have to be able to
protect the rich biodiversity that's on
our planet because we benefit from that
scientific researches is critical
because that gives us the information we
need to really understand what it is we
need to put our resources into
protecting
my name is Tracy Simon I'm the director
of The Wildlife Conservation Society
molecular lab based at the Bronx Zoo we
do a lot of diagnostic testing to screen
animals that are in our collection
we do PCR to monitor for a lot of
different pathogens we also help develop
portable technologies that we can take
into the field and really Empower our
researchers around the world to be able
to do diagnostic testing on the spot
my career trajectory has taken a very
circuitous path because I was really
interested in studying disease and
mechanisms of disease in particular at
the time I really thought I was going to
go into cancer research on the side I
started studying amphibians and this was
because I had met Anton Simon he's a
climate scientist who's now my husband
and he was leading Expeditions down to
Peru to understand how climate change is
impacting high mountain environments and
so on one of their expeditions they were
speaking to the local communities the
quechua communities who informed them
that they'd been seeing a lot of frog
die-offs Anton knew I worked in a
experimental pathology program and
reached out to me and so that's how I
came aboard the project
I love high mountain environments this
is an area that I've invested research
in over two decades now we've been doing
continuous monitoring of amphibians up
in the the upper reaches of the Andean
ecosystem this is probably the highest
herpetological site
up here it's at 17 000 feet
um what we're collecting is pleuredema
marmaratum amphibians they're basically
indicator species that tell us a lot
about how the environment is changing
what we're doing is swabbing these frogs
to test for amphibian kitchen fungus
first found amphibian
so as the Glaciers are receding you're
getting new ponds that are forming
higher and higher up when these new
ponds form that creates the environment
to where pollens get deposited up there
and microbes and that starts building
the soils and then those soils can start
allowing the growth of plants which then
bring up insects and so the whole
biosphere is actually rising in response
to the rising global temperatures
we also have a research part of the lab
where we take on projects with
collaborators some of that diagnostic
support has been through developing
e-dna tests Edna stands for
environmental DNA and it is DNA that's
Shed from organisms that exist in an
environment it's DNA that can be
captured through for example water
samples soil samples and even air
samples and it's a powerful tool that
allows conservationists to search for
rare and threatened species look for
evidence of specific species you can use
it to perform biodiversity assessments
to look at all the organisms in the
environment
our first uh area where we've opened the
door to Edna analysis for biodiversity
assessment was actually done on Mount
Everest in 2019. so the Expedition
actually was very interdisciplinary
pulled scientists from all all over the
world and so they needed some biologists
so our idea was to do basically collect
water samples along an elevational
gradient up to the highest ponds when we
were camping on on the glacier at
Everest Base Camp we were sleeping on a
moving glacier
and the sound of the crackling of the
glacier beneath your tent is you're
you're falling asleep in the thunderous
Roars of The Avalanches coming down it's
both um scary but at the same time it's
it's just amazing to hear it
[Music]
from these 10 sites that we identified
we collected to over 20 liters of water
when we brought that back to the lab we
performed
analysis of the the Edna that we
captured from the filters from those 20
liters of water
and we performed whole genome shotgun
sequencing so we sequenced everything
but we also performed DNA meta barcoding
where we targeted what you call a DNA
barcoding Gene
um which is a mitochondrial DNA Target
to then identify organisms often down to
the species level out of this analysis
we identified
187 taxonomic orders from 36 phylum
which is quite impressive it's it's
across the entire tree of life so we
identified everything from a few viruses
bacteria fungi plants animals
when you put into context the number of
taxonomic orders that we recovered from
these 20 liters of water when we compare
them to Total known taxonomic orders of
around the world we discovered basically
one-sixth of global taxonomic orders
just on this one mountain above 4 500
meters which is is quite remarkable
especially when you think about areas
around the Earth above 4500 meters
occupies only about three percent of
land mass it was quite striking that we
found that that level of diversity up on
the high slopes of Everest
I mean we are really pushing the
boundaries with trying to detect Edna
one of our projects where we're focused
on trying to detect this very rare
turtle species in Vietnam called rapidus
when oi which is the angsty giant soft
shell turtle our researchers can go out
and systematically test lakes and rivers
for the presence of this species and
it's really critical that we find
additional individuals in order to save
the species from going extinct because
they're they're really on the verge of
blinking out
as stewards of the earth we need to be
able to ensure that generations to come
benefit from the rich biodiversity on
our planet
[Music]